we don't have a new one yeah it's enough
it's on here Tim O'Reilly blow were some
fool podcasts were so full podcast
welcome to the were so full podcast
we're here every Friday and live on
Wednesdays on YouTube for those of you
guys who wanna listen to us on Wednesday
we go alive on Wednesdays on youtube.com
slash eighty cro3 goes back ladies and
gentlemen he's back he ate a shitload of
food we're gonna find out later how it
went what's up fool I'm back what's
happening happy to be back
well so we got least over here chillin
that pinky Tuscadero over here librarian
today - a ghost you get a Ghostbuster
remember Slimer cyber right takes a call
what's her stinky breath - another
version I don't know about the her
breath her stinking breath sly Murdock
yeah managed to be the fan she was like
a groupie of the show man she's to
invite her - she did not seen everything
about it anywhere but used to come to
the show all the time with her four
other friends she became a staple of
wild coyotes she's even she's even got a
[ __ ] plug on somebody the album
stinky breath the first album yeah by
the first album this one incident stinky
breath or she always had stinky breath
I don't know I never that the close
enough - Louis you have take a breath I
smelled it from the side one two digit
they say she started out fine like
really good-looking when it was Gotham's
and then like slowly she like became
Haggard
well I started out young dance custom
issue it is the same age
look ancient yeah man even big toward
[Laughter]
what I'll do yeah the only one act he's
the only one that care what type of big
dog a bro I want a chick to come up here
he with big deep with big tits whatever
right and then and then uh somebody
should I walk up there like it maybe she
go up there you know on stage to take a
breath and then a big dog see come on
Bella Coola in Spanish right but anyway
man yeah every time they ever like cool
the air right whatever so they know this
chick went up the right and she did have
a big big ass big boobs but then we were
loading hood man I said big ass big
bullseye big fat face big feet big
breath they read the good through her
drinking face yeah man so that was dig
deep breath bro shout out to all my
[Laughter]
she's just a big fan she might be
listening with this she uh I think she's
taking over what time she invited us to
go eat at her house and I couldn't
believe we went and I was through with a
gay bro and she made some more liberal I
had no more leaf flavor bro was male see
I feel like I love male rapper Athena
was morally but uh-oh bro
she and then III asked her did you make
dessert because solids cake on top of
the refrigerator man's abode ask a
brother while she's saving it up there
bro wasn't kink it was but a bundt cake
was frosty
throws off 400 rotten bro I think I
heard that food talking about it was bad
big dogs did that right she had a [ __ ]
you Ronnie cakey I don't know but what's
the big our first wedding I guess
you save your cake usually for the first
year they know Wesley was there too bro
Josh you struck me broke bro Josh um big
dollars assistant he looks like a
gangster with that fool and that's what
brought a homie remember I know you were
there but we went after the after that
up that dinner we had you know I ate ate
two plates
I put salt on it it's good after that
but I think Joshua told me we're back at
or it up the tow truck crazy dog oh my
god good times eh but it's funny man
like so they are like Oh foo oh [ __ ]
gay bro he were to do a short San
Antonio or somewhere in Texas and I
guess stinky breath have family over
there right and the first thing I heard
from here will ya bye hit breath things
to like a stinky breath family huh so
these bad how that [ __ ] happen even
though you have white teeth oh man [ __ ]
it Clorox bleach can't stop that [ __ ]
it's something in like the digestive
system right sometimes sometimes it's
there sometimes it's just in the mouth
but if it's chronic it's usually down
here in the digestive system yeah bad
tooth or something loose it could be a
tooth could do that bad - oh yeah man
you think if you have rotten penis think
yes be depressing
- but if you have if it's stemming from
something rotten in your mouth or some
sort of tooth problem then that could
cause a lot of other health issues
around your body like even like bad
gingivitis can cause heart disease you
know like yeah like the holistic
practice it started dental care there's
an infection and it travels through your
blood
all right now that it's over I just
overheard people talking about some dude
died because he had a bad tooth
it does happen though but you can go
into premature labor with gum disease
because of gun disease to do why it's
important when women before they get
pregnant if they're trying on purpose to
get pregnant that they get their teeth
cleaned and checked damn because you can
you can get a problem boo what's up we
missed out but everybody I heard was
blasting out their dog blasted cry what
happened sorry about those lingers
George for Buddha showed up bro share to
Westside something where say growers
knows brothers no envelope those know
this there's no advertising bro talk
about a million point five we're the
best ever was who knows what he's doing
bro I heard he's uh he said when they
call that when somebody's a name driver
[Laughter]
dude so he's the owner or the place I
guess he just worked for the man behind
the man dude it's not man behind a man's
oh yeah I don't even know what the real
story is man my whole thing is in
hopefully I'm not there when the FBI
kicks in the door I won't be there yeah
so other than I don't know I know how
those fools work there though Jerry
doesn't have a career in driving anymore
he's like a budtender I guess all
lucrative now what's there beyond now
one but beyond it is employing a lot of
people though yeah
homeboys got any cars and everything oh
they're falling out there Beamer no more
music it's all about the smoke bro you
don't see the Westside collective shout
out because they gave you sir - as I can
t-shirt yeah man not just a t-shirt yeah
they gave a lot of stuff and I gave my
last of please don't start giving
t-shirts to Felipe he has so many free
t-shirts I gotta let you know what my
free t-shirts I just wash my car with
them lassy sure the only way I take it
where they're soft those triple a's like
you get rid of you gonna make merch get
rid of stop using those thick-ass swap
me is type of t-shirts man you know
how's that we're right branded or Gildan
yeah basic beefy Hanes beefy even though
it's like a nice thick cotton but it's
not soft t-shirt merged well we use
something called next level like
American Apparel breathing yeah it's
like that American Apparel used to be
but we try to stay with the
american-made but it's getting there
fewer and fewer american-made shirts now
and even American Apparel most of their
brand was sold off to Gildan
now the Gildan who makes those scratchy
t-shirts and they they're American
Apparel side is made in Honduras now
yeah hey where's dick ass yours dude oh
dude I can't I can't even stand them
dude pro club put all styles we use
Bella in canvas when we can and we use
next level which are very close to the
American Apparel was so bull shot to
Mario right the good Mario Mario Ted
Cruz he did the fight reenactment
throw that little head locked up well
for you do that anyway so he drew Willie
Barcena
in a karate outfit in Aggie bro
he was drew I even drew a mix get a
little hairy right do the way it is
you're messing up my hair bro
yeah man you guys had fun with that huh
everybody have fun with that bro
whose camera everywhere bro hell yeah
man I was surprising a lot of comics
didn't back him up though you know
saying you know he's a good guy in this
and that
it happened after he started crying too
much probably the little guy said got
snarky bro who doesn't get punched when
you get snarky bro you can't get snarky
it had there were a lot of things going
on but a big factor in this was it was
his first punch ever so because it was
his first punch and their social media
and he was rulings and everything
immediately that's he popped his cherry
so yeah but he you know as it dude is a
comic I don't know you know cut that off
sometime stop talking about it I don't
know no dude I think it's just more like
on and on and like you know then it
became like Latino unity and what we got
to do as entertainers and then I was
just like dude after the second post I'm
like enough bro I'm saying don't they
have like a psycho therapist at the
Laugh Factory
you can talk to they do have a circle a
factory that is free and there's no the
post about comedians are asking me now
if I should work with this person
because he treated me bad I want to know
if I could work with him follow you
can't just follow your heart bro Polly
Lou tell you man if you have beef with
somebody and they're after you like $100
to work you know I will take it man you
know you need $100 but you know also
they're gonna be after you question man
so what's up with that formation about
you to start a little home gig just be
like Napoleon Dynamite dude follow your
heart that's what I do the eyes back I
come back oh really in LA
ah the kiss of death yeah oh my god
that's one thing about Coco dog he's a
good judge of character dog yeah
remember last time when that fool tried
to come back ouch try getting anyway
dropping my name with the experience bro
he's a piece of [ __ ]
nuf s'ti they're like you know what Joe
Rogan pose oh my god nuts already look
you know you know what last night was
all preaching about enough for a little
bit you know why we have cutting these
conversations I just found out what
happened tell us Baca got sponsored by
sucrets bro are you serious man give it
up for Henry Kelly 4/20
hell yeah bad bro you [ __ ] getting a
little [ __ ] snazzy right there with a
little [ __ ] wording right there but
that was funny man like like think about
it bro if you were if you were the guy
that was driving big dog around
allegedly after he punched me I gather
you're the comedian brother have to take
a driver to Vegas what's your what's
your what's your what's your oh your
mentality bro we're getting out of here
bro I'm gonna be like baby driver and
then before the car let's get out of
here I was big gonna return to [ __ ]
Denny's yeah man don't you guys we're
done with the gig right there what you
know Oh
three generations of ladies show up on
our getaway driver allegedly raw some
fool gonna show up brother and his
friend was talking to that dude lady I
guess and you better get out of here man
she's gonna show up for I saw it with my
cat
[Laughter]
yeah man well you didn't oppose Goerke
wooden name either you're coming right
I believe it's for Renee Baca right when
they box out out to Renee Baca for beat
Thelma Thelma Louise yeah Danielle both
have stories Brooke coming up already
dude I guess it could be dude but think
about it man I feel bad for him too
though because he thought it would it be
a nice tour hateful this wouldn't even
get to eat water burger does he know bro
really back up when did you finish
eating her look for Sony and our village
damn bro man who though feeling good
about the gig bro you know hopes and
dreams
it's called his mom back home yeah they
were doing they probably made a girl
they were supposed to be there later sir
a lot of stuff bro it happened when you
were an opener hell yeah
and then also there bro has to break up
a fight dogs did he get a restaurant
yeah they pulled him off is what we
heard who pulled him off the openers
yeah oh damn they don't fight bro when
they pull the bar bro
I think because the last move was a
choke
so that was lazy allegedly it's what
we've heard from witnesses he'd even hit
him with the famous Gordo duck there was
a hit I think there was a punch and a
maybe another punch and then uh and I
think with rolling with Willie it's
always gonna be like let's get out of
here yeah
remember that one time when we had we
know we were driving when he went off on
the dude at 7-eleven cuz he wouldn't let
him use a restroom and he told man you
can bomb our country but we can't take a
[ __ ]
have nothing to do with [ __ ] uh the
15 uh plane bombers or whatever Dubai my
friend
yeah man sucking in Saudi Arabia beer
damn man but he's trying with two
comedian in a funny man when I thought
Joe Diaz and that took sure that
wouldn't want me to be on first of all
Jodi isn't gonna be sitting no getaway
car dog solitary man what do you do bro
start the car I don't do that I would I
would like to see the video of that
place dude of him leaving dude whose
idea was it to leave but I think also
big dog smart enough to like give him a
cup of wax and then get in the car and
take off it ain't the first time he got
away it up it up that now dag
he's always been like the dramatic exits
dude remember in Oxnard when he took off
from the Calico store I was all dramatic
and that's because he had his back for
his homey Josh right his assistant then
hugged him and it wasn't it was all
dramatic dude he got I was there you you
already offstage quebra was on stage and
then I guess what's the name sent him to
go settle up he's uh what are you
sending him to me he looks like a
gangsta Willy bro that's my family dog
and then they got into it he's always go
bro he asked me if I wanted to go my now
bro I'm driving
[Laughter]
yeah man so I think I don't know I think
it's just well orchestrated from
experience do big dogs been getaway
since he had that little peek bug Doug
what time he told me that uh he uh he's
trying to fight with a road rage with
somebody right and Willie told me that
um that they they probably chose to the
gas station to fight and Willie got one
one cheap shot in but that foo didn't
fall and he said really hit up your car
brother do it kicking them it was to be
scary though oh yeah my head was dog
dogs back in the day that was disco
Willie then huh
how about anymore
nature's in the Mustang though they told
me water at the mall they should be a
fool in boats he knew I got him boost
they were boots all the time and we'll
it told me he round house therefore in
the mall and knocked him out I don't
know about that one I don't know about
round house he did I what he said before
jujitsu Willie I don't know man cuz he
round he tried to run a house those
spices over there and Rosemead and he
missed and that wasn't a complete round
house I was like a quarter house I think
which or scared them away with that
round house he was aiming for their head
but you know what stupid dog they would
have jumped over par left all alone
oh dude they were wearing those pointy
boots too but those prices weren't done
they were like kind of like they didn't
want to get into trouble dawg then all I
really want [ __ ] you November I know
your daddy you guys didn't have any more
adventures in the Mustang pool now man
nothing crazy
I remember just at one time somebody
burned down the car after wasn't him
borrowed in the big Bam Bam oh that hey
we don't say bad words on this show dog
but so cool how was that I saw that you
were in Mexico and one in Mexico you
learn you got one other God or the
cartel effete eco that a pretty cool
cable car
yeah they have the new ones that hold
your big-ass dogs yeah did if it holds
uh I'll be scared only four people at
all Oh baby
dude we were up at least like I want to
say about 3,000 feet yeah yeah I just
saw on a cable and it was cool it's all
modern it's all glass only four people
but it doesn't stepped on that dude
looked at me go
yeah just for you know what to the wood
to go buy cheese whoo I walked into the
Mercado guys I'll kill one of them who
the boss enemy
I guess can't be coming over all like
puffy dawg they don't worry that booth
over there
but they're different I know they're
like body fat like a lot of fools with
skinny hands and skinny faces but big
ass bodies hard stomachs or what I'm
under hell yeah a lot of floor shook my
hand hard yeah there's a lot of fat food
but I get I guess you could tell like
different fat I guess I was like
facially fat and hand fat you're a happy
face everybody the [ __ ] last time you
came you weren't that fat to make me not
go back family had a funny ass joke
though about some food it was really fat
no there's some little fat photo damn it
I think I'll go back I said okay and
that was okay way by now and then that
foot goes up to the next day care that
way you know way look at his discus
anyway committing a microneedle cemetery
molest Alma away which is [ __ ]
[ __ ] but yeah they're like very anti
fat over there dog even more than here
knows what's wrong fat yeah dude but
like a lot of sickly fat though they're
like you can tell there's like a lot of
fools they don't have dialysis out there
dog so the more people with that thick
Comanche skin you can tell like them
there's a lot of sick people out there
man and I think the poorer you are the
sicker you are of course the more rest
if I go there for you be a sticky gun
ticket but yeah it's weird because you
think that like it's adapted to like us
like you have McDonald's and all that
[ __ ] there's a lot of small ass fools
over there dog I kind of felt big dog I
was huffing and puffing though dude
walking because it's all like pills and
[ __ ] dude in downtown oh my god I got to
step two other steps a [ __ ] got like
thirty thousand one day we walked
everywhere dude I haven't walked this
much I didn't walk this much in Mexico
City Don it was all uber over there and
over there in sucka thick guys did he
call the uber it takes them 20 minutes
to show up
yeah oh wait so you all in statistics
yeah just suck up that cuz dude cousin
got married so we went out there to say
what's up
it was a daughter of my uncle the passo
that go there oh that believed you had
that was the best food I had over there
a little restaurant dude I saw that GU
the ritual yeah yeah and she uh she she
grew her radishes her onions all that
stuff was homemade and I was a little
bit big there's three sisters yeah they
have have they have medium in large dude
it was real good like my you know you
know when you eat my new though
sometimes a little tough yeah my teeth
cut through all the pieces the Minamoto
Oh super bomb super fresh I really
wanted to eat two bowls but everybody
saying I was with toast or tortillas
tortillas dog hell yeah bro nah bro I
want toes bro they don't have any
preservatives so they get hard fast but
they taste bomb dude the tortillas right
yeah dude put a little bit of lemon so
roll it up that my grandmother would
shoot my grandmother and everybody that
were in Tewksbury I'm pretty sure is
everywhere but this area everybody
bought the tortilla at that tortilla
whatever they make tortillas when before
they closed and they were eaten
immediately bro they were not never
nothing same because the same people
were back to nice day to buy more - yeah
every day you eat for the day yeah dude
it's very like in that no yellow
compared to over here a real hard corn
but you gotta eat don't know when you
come ugly it really hard yeah man the
flour ones that I make they get hard
just like that even anything no
preservatives do your mouth when they're
bomb that's the best way
so yeah the tortillas with the pozole
and that was all in red for like
railroad it was like it was like not
blood red dude but like dude just really
really red dude good red
you got a happy fat gang by that ever
you spell valparaiso roundout super
porky a I'm gonna play a game with the
log is what the river laughs I gave no
guest today we have no guest today we
have no guest dog well she was a guest
yeah he's from Mexico so uh what's up
usually taco the gift I only ate tacos
once we're at it was that a sad oh no it
was a loud Pastore but it was in my car
passed out on the wheel I think they
were already done with it so they had
them meet like they do it here they eat
it on the side at some Club si which was
alright was the best thing that I had
was the milita's a carbon solid again in
a fresh fresh flour tortilla bomb cheese
and then the meat cut up in there that
was bomb the the tacos were whatever I
didn't go to the bomb taco spot oh just
one day we came late and then we went
walking around that was only place that
was open but the Cassetti is were the
bomb at the wedding was at main course
the main course was a piece of steak a
little steak or a piece of salmon
wrapped with bacon and drizzled with
some kind of sauce everybody were not
lethal what happened bro don't be Leah
or that everybody does that huh no
that's more like if you're gonna do it
in your in your house or your ranch or
whatever this was different like loses
at a salon or a hall but yeah that was
it
my cousin went of wedding they had a
cool dobro they had a band 2 bands and
it was I were at a pad dude no no studio
no no I'll try Lord it was backyard
there are two bands and they made like
three big a sports bra bill yeah and
they passed that out to everybody like
everybody there was rice beans goat meat
salsa chips and that's a gas cake and
that's more traditional style because
that's how my parents got married but
they invite the whole town like if you
want to go there and party that you
don't have to bring a gift or nothing if
everybody so funny maker there was a
brother standing outside what y'all
doing we just gave him a player bro
that's it oh but that was here in the
States okay
what kind of meetings is goes de hell
they know yeah people are feeding me
goat I trip out when people go that's
gross let's go but it's like my whole
day you eat hot dogs right just butt
holes in lips and snouts and all that
[ __ ] that go get cold bro yeah yeah be
hot
surely go [ __ ] like with dinosaur
pound yeah
same thing with menudo when it like it
hardens up and gets all gelatinous and
stuff it's nasty in France they call
that cold feet they basically cook it
and eat it in its own gelatinous fat the
bread bread they'll like have it'll be
pieces of duck and in its own fat and
it'll be all in the hardened fat and you
take some off and spread it on a toast
or whatever I'll probably do one thing I
did was BOM was a little dessert they
had and I've never had a little tart
like that no super bomb and then it had
a little thick piece of like sugary
Miami hell had a heart attack
oh my god lady says bro this is the best
car planning Colombia and I don't know
was that much yeah you know I never get
to reseed clever but I saw that you know
90 cents bro for a little over little
Cortado 14 oh yeah it was just coffee
and sugar and then she gave him a bunch
of little cups you could take your time
you know yeah man and then you see the
lady we should make it she mixes it real
fast with the sugar and that's why we
always get off the flight Miami you go
straight to that when they had the
little cart you'd be just chucked four
or five of them real quick espresso or
it's a regular roast coffee I want to
say it's expresso and I've never been
there's this place right here oh you'll
I went there for like Cuban coffees not
the same same thing Porto's it's not the
same how about a capital P Karen said
it's pretty good but it's not it's not
as bombers over there dude
yeah man what we went there we've got
coffee outside first drag that [ __ ] they
went inside and it's ordered a bunch of
food rice bananas you could buy Nana's
look for Carlos salad yeah I was and
then now we would another coffee outside
yeah Ross look bomb to you man it was
good I could pretty much his taste it
dude
remembering Oh and what'd you go to wash
I want to go to an interview and
Telemundo and Miami in some old building
they're moving their building to another
city
they were big telemundo complex they
built but it was an old building and
releasing but now they're gonna have
their own building fool at this place
there's no Starbucks kiosk and that was
a video of that I'm latina lady she'll
making me a Cuban coffee right there in
the studio and how was it delicious okay
cuz she did she's the one who put in the
sugar but to all the ladies no wonder
we're not wearing the green outfits that
was harbor science but they were still
good coffee clever science is owned by
you know I got it out because we have
Versailles different different nothing
to do with them but I had copy here to
ever side it wasn't the same I want to
try something yeah Versailles has not
pleased me once with their food so here
there you go that's the one here though
I've never been in the one in Miami how
was the bread though soft bomb yeah the
French roll yeah fool I told that lady
give us some extra bread extra bread and
give it up avocados Tyler because the
avocado started arguing and avocado fool
rest up [ __ ] have a kind of toast and
Drake that car before a food got there
oh yeah cuz I was gonna ask you what are
you gonna substitute the butter with an
avocado olive oil
one thing that was bomb out there in
Mexico was the bully I haven't had them
in a while
oh yes the outside warm in the middle
dude dude I had others cheap better are
they are over there here cheaper over
here like by for a dollar the war
the cheaper dog and I had a bomb-ass
gotta meet as a torta dude forget about
it
the food set were sighted over price you
telling me dog in their Rancho Nova
Scotia adventure exploit word with
change alright what's up fool upcoming
shows Schomburg dog hell yeah well
Chicago bro that's what's up to cover
the Schomburg next week world
June 15th through the 17th at the
Schomburg improv outside of Chicago
tickets are going fast people badass
smaller to you we went there fast one it
was like a hundred five degrees we
walked over there and the locusts were
were there somewhere hell yeah it is
you were the left them over there yeah
man we took we took a train that it was
jus kago early in the morning hell yeah
30 minutes away 40 I think yeah on the
train that's the whole day trip back
there's some guy wants you to go to
White Sox game Kenny we go there always
easy no no I think it's a Saturday of
that week but I have to check it out
check out the timing we have to show
that Saturday right yeah also people I'm
coming to a Paso Texas at the Plaza
theater June 22nd the next day San
Antonio Texas June 23rd at the Tobin
Center first show is sold out second
show at it so there's a 10 o'clock show
now so if you didn't get tickets for the
inner clock show don't worry there's a
10 o'clock show now so hurry up and get
those tickets Orlando Florida
what's up boo June 28th through July 1st
at Orlando improv that's right
Lisa's family will be there man
I'll be there Thursday on Thursday 3000
[ __ ] just a tit comedy and magic club
what land only Hermosa California July
17 also if you're watching me on youtube
live you're gonna hear the big
announcement right now I'm gonna be at
the Comedy Store tomorrow night 8 p.m.
Thursday night at the Comedy Store
Skyler stones show if you're worried on
what some full podcast t-shirt or any
Philippe inspires a t-shirt I will give
you my downloadable album I'm gonna have
some of my pocket if you're at the
Comedy Store Thursday night and I'm
sorry if you listen to it on Friday June
7th June 7th Jul 7 in case people are
watching this at 11 tomorrow June 7 I'll
be at the Comedy Store a p.m. what
several shows coming up June 12th uh
we're gonna be in Riverside at the Fox
Theater myself luck with Martin Rizzo
Viva Las joke show brought to you by
Division 9 glory a p.m. 10 bucks at the
door please come out in the laughs a
free show I can no longer do it because
I'll be in a Illinois Schomberg improv
with Philippe so we'll do it next time
was so full army oh boy oh [ __ ] Henry
Colleen 4:20 10 bucks 10 bucks
he was just in Austin and March 31st I
was just lost in March or it goes to
just a pillow hold me right here Aaron
Aaron is by plants for shake our my show
that Philippe is WorldCom for our coming
shows also man you guys don't know this
but uh have you ever heard of simple
context oh yeah simple context is a
revolutionary
contact company that um sends you
contacts to your home comfortable
context that you can try out at your
house and decide whether or not you're
gonna keep them or not
and they're very comfortable there are
very decent price and here's how it
works using your phone number or
computer you can take the simple contact
using your phone or computer you can
take the simple contact vision test in
five minutes for literally anywhere you
did the right of five minutes it was it
was less than five minutes yeah yeah I
had a good experience in a real doctor
will review your test in 24 hour and
writes you a new prescription and boom a
fresh supply of your brand of lenses is
on the way to your door no more
appointments no more waiting rooms no
more overpaint
simple contacts brings the doctor office
to wherever you are whenever you need it
so they send you a box you think you're
not because we're doing the ad but you'd
like to read to me before is Deanna yeah
what I did was is I got my prescription
I went on the site I did it all on my
iPhone I uploaded my prescription I
looked at what kind they had had dozens
of view oasis and I ordered them on a
Saturday night and they came on
Wednesday ready to go it was super
simple and they hit you up with the
prompt and you fill that out and then
they'll send you an email to confirm and
then they'll let you know that they're
on their way and they track it all the
way for you and within about four days I
had my contacts so he did he already had
a prescription yeah so he just sent his
in but if you don't have a prescription
you can renew your prescription as long
as your eyesight is about is the same
you can renew it and take a test online
and if you have an unexpired
prescription just upload a photo of it
you or your doctor's info and order your
lenses in minutes for a great price they
do all the hard work for you simple
contacts offers every brand of lenses
and their prices are are unbeatable the
prescription is just twenty dollars the
contact lens prices are super
competitive and shipping is free best of
all my listeners get $30 off their first
simple contact order
to save $30 on your lenses just go to
simple contacts calm /foo or enter the
code full that's fol and check out I
want to mention that this isn't a
replacement for your periodic for eye
health exam
you still need to you still need those
occasionally but it is the most
convenient way to renew a prescription
and reorder your contacts if your vision
has changed again check out simple
context and get $30 off by going to
simple contacts calm / fool or just
enter the code fol and check out and
Rodrigo looking good man at first sight
I hate looking at a cross sided fool
though because I had a question a true
liberal walleye Wally I don't know have
you ever looked at somebody's cross-eyed
I kind of goes or you think like
mentally it'll go
[Laughter]
so he hides it whatever whatever we were
like - we were blazing outside in Austin
Austin right a little wild man
the little little Y little I was asking
me wanna be on the podcast again hello I
said alright I'll do it again
one so full shout out to Artie's comedy
shout out to Aaron if you've got five
dollars you go what are you gonna do are
you able to cover Santa Barbara for
Fiesta in August or too many green guys
for you bro I got me a green here right
here dawg
do we want more why Morgan Gus people in
general to Nova Scotia adventures and
explored
bring George Carlin back from the grave
does it give us um George Carlin bro
but bust the old man yeah it was funny
that you guys brought up you know Morgan
geyser Morgan INGOs my cousin got all
drunk he was telling his lady how about
a threesome she's our Seaway yo yo you
those way is yeah dude it was actually
like way way more now dude three years
it's increased a lot of Europeans I ran
into two British fools living over there
happy just vacationing they said that
they're on their way to Monterey after
that but yeah sprinkle does the old
colonial city do it so people go over
that they got old
yeah it's built in the late 1400s
between anything new over there you
never had but fresh cheese no nothing
that I've never had before there no I
got that be NOLA for you though oh [ __ ]
thank you I haven't tried it though you
can do it with soy milk or wait da has
to be super super hot all fools speaking
of the doctor I watch mine I went to a
podiatrist first time I'll put someone
else inside he cut my toes bro told me I
was bro oh I never have the dough by
anybody she wouldn't do it either I
would not say that he's perfectly he's
perfectly healthy so anyways what
happened he breaks your beverage for the
fastes gababa shame bro let me tell you
do you buy cheap toenail clippers dude
that's what you're gonna get
well who had an ingrown toenail that was
killing me right all right but I [ __ ]
what performing like a soldier right I
let it go let it go by whatever right
there's pain then Sunday night my
[ __ ] toes like I'm gonna like a big
bro like I'm gonna get yourself gonna
get your sucker
don't ever [ __ ] all MRT more and on a
good day bro it will say you know wha
like when like my team would've got that
is toast dog brought a [ __ ] guitar
pedal bro no for slaughter let me hit
Sonny he's broke it off with him it was
infected I put some elbow o fool I was
cheating myself in a bathroom bro like
[ __ ] you have your birthday cut you were
no man no Senshi for old no coaching for
old man bro like the predator probably
blew up the pharmacy think about
anything I guess treat himself that's
how I was treated by tow bro I put a
bunch of hot water stuck my foot inside
and then I put the [ __ ] funny
I love butter rice Hobie anyway so I
[ __ ] it Oh treating myself bro then I
got to [ __ ] it up some other
destinations to clean it out put the toe
back [ __ ] you know pus camera
everywhere bro it was like popping a
pimple well anyways dog I cleaned that
one you know that [ __ ] I did all that
[ __ ] that that I had to do but before I
did that I had to go to the Internet to
find out how could I [ __ ] with it
without getting [ __ ] up right just so
they say be ghetto floss you could do it
all without flaws yeah you talk about
this floss and I put the toe bag was
hurt
anyways I did what a cool butcher
survive for another two days and then
Sookie was sleeping a bit my foot out
the blanket it's the worst pain ever if
you ever want to [ __ ] with somebody hard
if you know that fool has an ingrown
toenail just smash that Grover bro the
other foot don't lie to people
so much it's the yep so what the played
phantom pain this is Oh laughter
esharbro
he says makes up a [ __ ] you know the
appointment appointment to see a
podiatrist right Northbridge get the
boys like this these Armenian shake my
age bro with [ __ ] blonde hair bro
a little eyebrows she to take her down
boots off after when he came back from
shooting people during the Russian war
bro bro she look like this doctor look
like she with her devil call for work
she would take his shoes off and they
socks off and then crack his totally
rubber feet and did the callous and out
of her feet she's experienced wonder
ways we're talking and then she's
telling me well you know there's another
option and I said one other option I
could pull these nails out heavier pull
the nail out any [ __ ] grew back bad
yeah
well this trip just try better super
sweet cherry Bukit Barisan [ __ ]
so can I guess the birthday girl from
Mexico right now so she said we gotta
take a blood test I got blood test [ __ ]
I got better [ __ ] better better see you
got right now
then then you gonna give you a
prescription for today I gotta take a
blood test for your medicine I got
better medicine coming from Rodrigo
blood test is for safety it has to be
good it'll call him fat a week put the
pH where anywhere dude she was geez when
i sat there the other nurse man these to
cheat that work they're doing for comedy
bro Libre came here with a rounded toe
hey don't you eat that [ __ ] I hate that
[ __ ] by the way a photo mm oh my god so
I took a photo bro holy put my [ __ ]
sock in my hand that is GD I wanted to
that's what I'm saying so she said she's
dead
while I took my [ __ ] socks off she
came here dude
she said that I'm gonna clip your
toenails and I'm gonna take it to a lab
lab [ __ ] who do I kill just tell me
right here you got the green with the
Grimm killer of each I could have done
that I could have took a photo of my
toenail sailor to [ __ ] Google
comeback was what's wrong with it more
money yeah so she had to take it to a
lab it gets a little DC now so dude yeah
I figure out how to grow toner right
right she [ __ ] you I don't know how she
did it but um she said oh yeah and I'm
gonna take her in your toe now I'd have
to get a will away your take her right
now prepared I suppose I'm gonna dip my
foot of water and hot my [ __ ] tongue
are hard right now can we get a dip in
the hot water for two hours let my tone
down stop it at least soak that leg I
went to swim pool brush it was dry
nothing it [ __ ] cuz I don't think it
also man it's funny you're up bracing
yourself for the pain that you're tired
I walk like but you look good I was
thinking also of the horrible toenail
clipper we have a hole that she works
how it's painful something about that
pain can pass out bro she came over some
[ __ ] perfect pliers I don't know how
she did it dude but she [ __ ] hit me
she [ __ ] took care of the toes the
other toy I was a bad and then I don't
know what those pliers dude I felt a
sharp pain real fast and the real fat go
away in did she just lift it up in the
air and then she cut yeah that's right
perfect
so what's she telling you about not
having ingrown toenail what's the key
she said that they gonna they're gonna
go back she couldn't she couldn't she
couldn't so the toe could grow on wiggly
hourly so the total are growing up and
the the top part is gonna keep growing
the way through grow the middle part and
then by the time the little parts are
growing it'll just follow the problem is
if you cut your sides too low
too low that's how you're gonna get
ingrown toenails you should cut all your
nails straight across because any cable
design yeah you go into the skin like
that you're gonna it's gonna in that's
what I'm trying to do right now let them
all grow I don't have one but I can feel
little pains of reminisces of having
ingrown shouldn't go beyond the skin cuz
my mom would not pull that [ __ ] back
mama would take us and do surgery
because she has like Flintstone feet
she's been digging internship forever
and my dad fool cuts his toenails like a
werewolf okay somebody's drawers egos
mom with little toes and they're like
but she would be so get over here
somebody had to go bite on a bell and
dude it'll be like blood like something
on a shot of bird's head off my bears
are you go to jail you're good at the
doctor were you dying I ever thrown out
by the flu and it really message it will
go but dog anything day you can take
care of a broken resident [ __ ] that's it
master speaking of diet when I got so
doctors it was a fool in the foie gras
and like there were people that drove
those people there like older people
younger people who lift that toenail
like a sly dog
there was food came in food Oh put this
with doc I was the only one that walkie
no water there and I thought I was
[ __ ] up this lady came in with a crane
dog no she would like a little [ __ ]
scooter and I saw a big fat tow bro it
was swollen dog like nasty swollen they
had to rip that thing out they're not
pleased with the back about the head
yeah bro and then a low man showed up
too bro and then everybody look like
them like they shouldn't have been
ballerina that that wait that's it so
the podiatrists take care of ingrown
toenails okay and I thought that a lot
of people let it cool oh yeah you put
your foot about and yeah at least it's
not your foot
ten years with my footie Obama who I
pull it back it's cuz I feel bit like
sometimes if you don't go in there
you're not gonna cut it right into
that's but I know you have to get out of
that weird-ass thinking when I cut it
right cuz I envy people have nice little
straight little I just get all addicted
to start cutting [ __ ] let's cut straight
across and you should have a little tiny
bit above the skin like fingernails too
same thing these are the bad toes - no I
do not have a boner there was a lot of
victims and there are a lot of people
that are in need of he's probably like
the easiest one she saw morning this
lady came in a walker food there are old
people going in there yeah bro she came
in was good oh the one you put your knee
on your toes [ __ ] up but you're rowing
herself the new cruisers yeah like a
little scooter thing yeah Athena will
but Wendy for walking up with her
scaring the [ __ ] out of me bro
cuz I'm like I wouldn't want to be that
old with all that pain on the bottom
[ __ ] you don't want to be 65 with a go
Tony Oh bro neglecting me those who have
ingrown fingernails bro dude how the
[ __ ] you how fat is your hand on earth
huh bleep push-ups a we're at a party
what time eat Jerry and Vinny and there
was this fat fool that we know dog this
was fat as [ __ ] and he had a shoes off
I'll play the guitar we wait till we
left what's up man that fat ass [ __ ]
towing that little ass [ __ ] nail man
[ __ ] [ __ ] buried in fat ha man dude
this fools toe was that big and the
little nail was like that dog I don't
even know how that fool cut in sometimes
that nail doesn't grow very well
take care of feet yeah we just have to I
was telling Philippe the way when I
worked at the nursing home they were
diabetic patients and you had to like
soak their feet you had to do special
things to cut their nails you couldn't
just do it like everybody else
that was it on YouTube that you got out
you have to soak your feet for 25
minutes at 3 times a day and then you
told your toenail your soften and then
you cut it
did that podiatrist tell you anything
that it's myths about what you've been
doing with your toes up until the point
you went out there what's up it's the
lab it's fungus in the nail bed
oh that's back to Jerry his first wife
when she got married this lady she
worked with or girls that she worked
with I guess she had fungus on her toes
and they had to pull him out well
anyways I guess his girl got him pulled
out when they had the bachelorette party
he's checking it up blowing the stripper
dog excited they overheard the stripper
saying watching Marty Moreno and hooter
Moreno do your podcast because live on
YouTube for some reason I get alerts
like Mondays when I'm in my house
watching Seinfeld you know chilling my
rabbit your podcast like they would I
paid attention to the carbons right make
it sound in trolls I start strolling bro
I said right leave me comments under
your podcast because they were talking
about out how cooler was talking about
how I miss my mom oh yeah the kids
preschool starts too early and kid
starts toward it starts going to order
school and home schooling and then my
and then whoever was talking about when
I was going to preschool we went to this
so hudecki talking about him in
preschool and the kids in preschool
exactly but nobody got it but me
and I'm running and I'm typing forget
musty has no recollection I'm Anna
Winnie had pubes yeah little Marty
mehoudar talking about being a little
boy in a preschool when he was going in
a martini hat and I wrote down that's
shaking my hair Marty has nothing to add
he was too busy touring with lottery
I met hooter later after who's like kind
of a little but nobody got a dog cuz the
only ones I knew were kids that's it
everybody has a beard did they find out
you're a troll or [ __ ] with them for
know oh my god well it was me and Alex
Dolores bra and Mario only off we
probably firing those fools up Mario
gonna draw a photo of fwee preschool
[Laughter]
look at 4:00 you're right he's [ __ ] he's
fools they were they're wrong
hey you know what's funny about the
whole I was gonna go go back to what we
started at but with that whole comics
fighting each other I kind of didn't I
didn't look at it when I was over there
cuz I didn't looking at this [ __ ] but
you know what's funny dog all these
fools keeping me up to date with what's
happening and now this is p.m. for
comedy
jimbros got a dog hide and Ivy what are
the hot spots anymore where Hollywood
was the hot spots now well yeah comedy
spots let people know the hot spots in
in Hollywood they know but they never go
there oh yeah oh yeah shout to joy Coco
bro he got the Netflix last night before
right deserved man can't wait to see it
that was sad
I want to try it on Marty when he got
sold to a circus strong boy he does have
that body huh how about that toe is
black somebody said they slammed it with
one of those hammers here the the
fluckey on Rapoport podcast I know you
say he won't do your butt why not you
guys are cool go ask him Brook Gustavo
Hernandez that's a question you asked
lovely bro you asked him how come you
don't do the worst of a part can we have
two bro
you know there's an open call for some
people and they don't want what they
don't want to show up it's up to that
man wait that's because they're afraid
you know also bro we stop we're gonna
tell you that they're afraid that we're
gonna ask the hard questions
we're not hey fools where we're gonna
start bagging on him when they were
going around we're gonna ask question
you gonna go into memories of what might
come up I'm not saying he is I'm saying
that's his reason he hasn't given us a
reason he just hasn't responded people
are afraid
we'd like to cut away what I tried on
Twitter
I keep typing try right now bro please
[Laughter]
also messed up asking me when I'm gonna
be on the Joe Rogan podcast it's not up
to me mad I know no fool swear huh
yeah like is that easy yeah I want to go
I want to say I will go back three years
ago when first started this podcast that
somebody mentioned him on his timeline I
don't want to go back there and search
that [ __ ] you know when are you gonna
have a real Mexican on your podcast like
funny Felipe's are funny Philly he's
invited he's funny [ __ ] he's invited
him in person at the Comedy Store but he
won't
I mean Elkin [ __ ] what's up fool from
San Antonio Jose joke Carrasco Tamina's
name huh what software with kayaking I
watch your boy video how was that dude
that [ __ ] all Russian is [ __ ] just
relaxing scared us forever I'm saying I
want to first of all man we Airbnb it at
this badass little place right in front
of the bay dog is right on the water
right on the dock let run a dog man
right on the dock and we would call yeah
kina grown 9:00 in the morning but I had
questions I don't want to flip over get
back an abode she like that you're a big
guy go you're big guy big guy two times
don't lead to a don't need that's it
just cut through the middle just come to
a little yeah and it's going to be that
one for the Terkel to like you're a
[ __ ] River a [ __ ] suicide how long
you do it for did you guys were just
cruising right there in the bay I pass
by Franco a gang of seals they're all
cheer there bro oh yeah it's like a big
wooden that I saw a [ __ ] I wonder the
little
oh so do those eating a cottage
mother-daughter an otter I saw an otter
with her baby bro swimming a little at
food cool you like I will order like I
did that walk [ __ ] Berlin rah rah
doggies open the shell to the
[ __ ] ah and they went back in
the water I got another one what else
you guys do over there you guys go there
whoa super chill and relaxing
yeah there's no Starbucks there well
there's one like in the grocery store
down there yeah there's nothing it just
feels like a nice little it feels like a
town in Maine or something like you hear
the seals and maybe you like a foghorn
at night or something yeah it's cool
foggy as hell too yeah there's nothing
to do nobody out it was what Sunday
night or like 9 o'clock you could stand
out in the middle of the street nobody
there no cars nothing
we're leaving another stupid-ass bad
that are all served [ __ ] I was out
there people need a job I'm I saw grip
enjoyed the viewing didn't poo asked me
bro like those like some trash bags and
an ocean on the side would appear you
know anything about that
and I say about what he said do you know
anything about that
remember what about the trash bags like
nothing about that I did it and I said
ah but that's a diaper right there it
was an adult diaper like somebody was a
drop there or a pet owner but but that's
not a bag though that's a diaper an
adult diaper they just took quiet and I
dove to him when I said I hope he's all
right though cuz I [ __ ] diaper right
there
maybe he's shitty so work and wonderful
say why Oh bro idiot
[Laughter]
ain't no rat ain't no rat [ __ ]
maybe with that bag was there like since
my mate the day before the evening
before I noticed it - put this bag is
that the same place where you guys go
well watching no we go down to Long
Beach Long Beach area
yeah sometimes we go to Rancho Palos
Verdes right that a little spot no no
yeah yeah yeah yeah no we're the
lighthouses oh we go there is that Palos
Verdes okay yeah sometimes over there
that's cool the big cliffside you could
see the baby you can see those rich rich
area so they feel like California like a
turnout oh no something point yes every
same thing yeah seven cent tip
lighthouse and it's a it's a now service
at there it's by Long Beach and San
Pedro Bros that little bit or nowhere
but yes a lot cliffs mm-hmm
that's free that's nice to see in some
time but there's no guarantee you're
gonna see the whales but then we go on
the boat sometimes down from Long Beach
yeah right there that they were in the
recreation area was a picnic table to
know that and let me have a little well
Museo or something or fishing well
Museum but they have a lot of binocular
do people see whales from there very
cool yeah bad nothing nothing [ __ ] you
know every bond was killer huh hell yeah
bro Miami - man I will know the Comedy
Competition of Miami ultimate comedian
competition you ended up headlining I
think hosting yeah I got the hell Ari
I'm hell I did I started I ate there
like competition and then the announcer
winner he won $5,000 oh [ __ ] yeah then I
went up and it close out the show I met
everybody that trying to make it back -
good another coffee they were close
because that was what time 9:00 or 10:00
9:00 sort of Taco Bell in the casino no
no I remember now what time we walk for
how long we walk dude to go to like that
one time because we thought it was all
closed and we just kept on walking kept
on walking we ran into that Cuban dude
they said
all fooled by a growing up what happened
focus who showed us America show 10
family needle a mutual partay oh I
really do is he wanted to hang out - I
was hanging out with that one dude that
one dude but it was me during this full
set and two girls were hanging out they
weren't hanging they thought they came
with him but they were just talking to
him oh yeah I got two daughters I got a
daughter she's like your age so you have
a daughter my age is off what is it
against the law
oh yeah oh my god that fool is that
Miami show right and slitted the mayor
of Miami Springs the boy who invited me
to the Marlins game you guys okay yeah
he was there too but uh I forgot he
showed up but he asked about you he goes
hit the medical you were doing getting
married huh anyway he told me he called
hey so what's up yeah what's going on
with that man I was like what married
life what are you talking about somebody
this dream started last week it was from
your party
the celebration of America okay well you
know they could be my brother was sad he
was a brother and you guys yeah so love
story short man this guy man we met him
the first time whoever went to the
memory problem and he gave her his card
and in the car in the back of the car
and the front of the car you said they
does fancy and he puts up gates he does
a lot of construction work right but but
he wanted he wanted to let him know that
he really gets [ __ ] up too so on the
back of the card he also he wrote but
what I also do is PA r /t a a and his
phone number
but what I also do is par-tay he's been
partying for a long time and then he
showed up the next day after that right
alone because the first time shooter
with a lady and the next day he showed
up alone was three joints and he takes
it to the he takes us to the roof of the
club
hello parking parking lot he goes be
renew those hobby that you were cool
like I wrote some people happen some
people don't but that's one of those
guys it's just there to smoke you out
give you a couple high fives and he's
out in the Father does it bug nothing he
like joint cocoa huh yeah dude like you
know crazy a Cuban fool huh they'll
smoke well with you and then two for the
road dog look at goes bro yeah he's like
with a heart made for party and you can
like run cocaine through that [ __ ]
drinks committee showed up again another
time with a lot of fools man they were
all for curator party was it the last
time the Coconut Grove was happening
yeah well like they all came out of a
boat cuz I remember that one time when
we met him was that week they who seen
the dice yeah the day before your show
started their partay yeah man I forgot
his name dude how do those night Hannity
look like a guy that'll be driving
Willie's getaway car Miami huh give us a
bundle bro Hobbs bro bro right here bro
taking care of family business
was so fool so though the allowed job
that went down bro yeah but I pretty
much allow me with a pipe in India IRA
what they approached me this one time
$50.00 I know posted yeah he approached
me to you
everybody had a story bro whatever what
I got victims on that yeah what I gotta
tell everybody that's crying or
everybody has something to say that's
great dude but to us I was just another
Wednesday night in Montebello man it was
always something with that fool always
something you're trying to start and
start [ __ ] with you and [ __ ] and then
[ __ ] out comes over here you don't it
could stop this and here's all tell that
for if he doesn't turn around I'm gonna
beat his ass dog and that's what around
goes back in there start [ __ ] with Josh
what the [ __ ] dog how about we thought
he started [ __ ] with my little buddy
he's got the bike was well he grabbed
the helmet I have a picture oh I have a
picture of a [ __ ] idiot
put the helmet on his helmet without
Steve job yeah did I have the picture of
it somewhere I'll find it they got bad
huh yeah and then they grabbed him and
supposedly he went to grade school with
one of the leaders so they had to put
him on the phone and then they looked no
he called up a guy named I don't know
his name but he thought he was from the
Mongols of Echo Park chapter against he
grew up in Willie and Silver Lake and I
don't know his name good tomorrow when I
remember they had Willie on one side and
they had two other the phone the guy I
was talking on the phone so you know
this guy he welcomed I there Willie
the real sleepy boy they woke him up and
Willie was yelling come on bro
tell him about Little League tell me
what new league bro
travel balls hello bro tell her bro tell
about Little League they finally let him
off the hook though yeah they're like
two year later I run into that guy they
woke up and I fool was crazy dogs
crazy and F would say man if you ever
see him try to do that again yeah
because it's funny because of that
incident then they invited Willie to the
clubhouse and me and two other people
went out but right out Josh and that was
a whole like I guess he had to go over
there and like you know and then all
those guys had their girlfriends and
that's the only time we'll eat
like you know what really gets all happy
starts moving his head off good do it
doggy dog he was all like everybody mind
your business everybody like by those
guys beers you're the one [ __ ] up pull
out your wallet dog yeah man everybody
bumping you guys yeah dude that's just
how they are
come on sir clubhouse dude it was crazy
because those fools like they patted us
down we went through a metal detector
those dudes on the roof it's all
official dude it's true they have
snipers yeah I do
so it's all official yeah those that
actually cop cards around the shrimp
cards around the whole entire perimeter
I don't know that they pay for him and
[ __ ] cases in case [ __ ] goes down
I wasn't shakes a lot chicks yeah but
they are they were all property of some
dudes you know Ken there was no chicks
for us put it that way about food dog
who's next I think there was chips dude
there was a lot of beer though
a lot of beers little games they have
the old school ones like Street Fighter
and all that [ __ ]
it was a real Mouse it was a clubhouse
it was a straight-up Clubhouse and that
bars there bar ha they're gonna pay huh
yeah I do you know you had to pay for I
think with tickets and stuff yeah it was
all like you know like a fare or some
[ __ ] yeah you were there twice no I just
wants to come and do that fool brother
helmet yeah you know what's funny - this
wouldn't want to go by himself dog take
me bro it was always something with that
fool I remember at the walk out he got
so [ __ ] up he made out with like an 80
year old lady and I know he doesn't
remember this and that was around the
same time within about three weeks give
or take of all that [ __ ] anyone for the
hospital or what - if so she would show
up every now and then it was like
somebody's great-grandma like oh one of
those old Chicanos it still does her
hair blonde she was old dog oh oh yeah
she was a Titanic bro
like yeah dude like she went to high
school with somebody's mom or grandma
she was old she was back then dog mm
three she had to be 70 and that's how
[ __ ] up that would fool get cuz
remember you stopped drinking he'll take
it light you wouldn't do any tequila
I guess that night he did a lot of
tequila yeah a do lady she was old cuz
remember in the tearing it up no I don't
think you tear though he made out with
her though he kissed her dog like on the
lips I don't know if you it looked like
he was positioned on her for a while dog
you threw a little tongue a little
tongue little swipes in there dude meet
in the middle yeah before that [ __ ] how
old is either the next vehicle I'm so
cool Walker a bat pancreas but you know
what's funny dog I've never seen that
for with the cold sore dog that lean old
road is she having she has a robotic
play Coolio bro well clearly it was wild
huh it was really wild company people
have met their wives at that place I'm
saying lady to me it would make me laugh
dude of the guys that would hang out
when like way before my time they said
like prime cut or gotham's and they'll
show up like they went to the store to
go get like milk or cigarettes there and
they'll still think what are you talking
about we can't party go go buy two
scooters and start looking around for
people that have cocaine because needs
to go there and do cocaine back in the
day to thousands here for this 20 years
that you parted here the place got
raided one time for Coke for Coke
dealing and all kind of stuff and they
arrested and if they do the bartender in
prison a lot of girls waitresses and
then it reopened again and walked
tortillas yeah they had nothing to do
the owner they were just the people
working there people working cuz I
remember when fools would go there like
they would hang out with you guys in the
past and they're not you know I talked
to that fool then they'll come up to us
all like trying to buddy-buddy up in
like tell us stories like Chris Dorian
just joined what story bro
we go bro nice meme bro hey the bay came
in hard that wasn't a har the bay okay
butch Escobar came in they're all in fun
game of thrones awful the bearer was
ready bro no real crystal will have that
mean four years bro was the best meme of
that lady dog that she had we die do it
I couldn't even believe it does actually
like this bro yeah be choked by Willy
right now I'm shaking I'm at the Village
Inn
help me with a vodka hey Willy off me
this weekend and I saw those glasses
also come do a show on watch yeah bro
back in the day come see the comedy
store it's right know anybody watching
this show man I'm gonna be at the Comedy
Store
tomorrow tomorrow June 8th 7 June 7 8
o'clock show ok so be there man if you
wear the t-shirt or you wear anything
what so fool I'll give you my [ __ ]
album to download my new album translate
this Chris storm your son Chris Dorian
bro but what happened bro how'd you come
over that meme bro I got a whole library
I mean bro just waiting for incidents to
pop off bro go warriors brow take a bro
bro we're gonna take it but I don't want
nobody from Frisco to say they're
warriors fans bro it's all about okhla
bro all those crew hopping fans over
there does at least that flew to us
buddy man you know who showed up out of
nowhere who Ray or time Super Mario Bros
from corpus oh that fool busted out the
mean that they other fool man huh Mario
Roy Raymond north I just punch me and
I'm shaking pretty funny Raymond had
anything to do it though they just don't
know him
yeah just hopping on a little thing but
is that has to do with their little
Texas beef right yeah man it's full roll
it's cooled ba9 the big bay area
everything's cool about the barrier bear
except for e-40 dog now for us to Kela
now really [ __ ] out here
that's akela a 40 yeah and see the one
who had a heart attack no thumb he's
live that's Rick Ross viagra that
coconut cocaine yeah but if he had a
cocaine if it's hard has been damaged
from cocaine over the years then I was
like yeah yeah I mean you can't be out
there all healthy man you better put
that milligram down dude what's up fool
shall I tell the homies in San Jose man
shout out to everybody man in San Jose
I'm gonna be at the Warfield theater
Bravo vember second you heard and we're
going to the Raider game that was what
to the Raider game before the day before
Thursday night football large 49ers
we're gonna be a Levi's Stadium last
season performing Oh bull Chris Dorian
are you still there bro
you still there bro hello long long long
long time ago I did a show in San
Francisco with Emmy Kurt I did a show
one time with any current right and now
I made a dude after my show in San
Francisco and he took me to a liquor
store their soul drinks mixed drinks
it's a [ __ ] liquor store in Daly City
in Daly City California as well as by
the I guess it's by arm Daly City
training 38 minutes away from San
Francisco I guess it's called the
something liquor barn Caffrey in Daly
City bro and you go there just say you
want to buy a mudslide and
the mudslide ingredients are in a
plastic bag with all the ingredients so
you want a mudslide
you get pick it up out of the out of the
box out of a bag it's got like the
little travel-size oh yeah vodka or
Kahlua or whatever which allowed
the mixtures they're in the air bomb
right right on the bottom of the [ __ ]
well the ice cream go they have to go
cups with ice already so you could make
that [ __ ] up in your car and drink it on
the way home or drink it outside but
it's kiaro as [ __ ] daly city it's a it's
a liquor store it's like being able to
go and buy it yeah it's like it's like
going to the club and buying a mixed
drink but you're buying the inside of
into the liquor store but you're legally
buying it they're not giving it to you
already mixed you gotta mix yourself
into that cup like whatever you do when
you leave this liquor store that's my
response hillside market it's the
hillside market liquor store in Daly
City you been there fool yeah we got
everything over here bro dude oh I went
there was a guy and he goes you wanna
get some drinks sure and I went over
there bro and that food but I think back
then when I went they were still giving
him in the cups and that fool had a
big-ass cup bro makes like a mudslide
that's like a bomb those are like 20 so
that's only in the bay huh bro I guess
so Brown that's how we do it over here
bro yeah basil shout-out to the hillside
market genius bro ghetto genius girl
genius it's like selling loosies you
know yeah yeah similar thing like here's
all the ingredients you can assemble it
yourselves wherever so that's good don't
know how to make but but these people
who buy these alcohol drinks it at a
hillside market in Daly City are part of
the same people that walk into the punch
line or carbs
Tommy tees Saturday improv and it'll
many [ __ ] drinks are weak I can't
ghost ride the whip with this bro big
bad Bakersfield at our house oh yeah you
and Dwight Yoakam was so full shout out
to everybody there that I've got
involved Chris Torres
Bush Escobar Pete munos Nick Guerra
Willie Barcena [ __ ] out though the
rapist we can say his name
can you come out his name anymore the
rapist there it is brother rapist you
wanna know where huh
hi Rivera got your ball bro shout out to
him oh my god what's up fool okay shout
out we're gonna go before you go give us
a little barbecue Becky dog yeah man
they're over here doing a whack ass
podcast yeah things got a once-off full
party the two million Mexicans one white
girl yeah I just got punched by Willie
Barcena AJ Massa Montebello yeah man he
[ __ ] threw my corn dog on the ground
it's [ __ ] up man
oh my God we're so 4-3 or any shows
comin to ya man please new yeah man's up
please check out our show and represent
at the Fox that's Tuesday June 12th at
8:00 p.m. on myself also man everybody
who listening right now man please write
a review of our podcast share like it on
iTunes that's why we could be in the top
200 thank you
Vibha USA